if you see that you have a curious kid
you need to become a cheerleader of that
if they want to cook one weekend let's
go if they want to rock climb let's go
if they want to pick up a Guitar cool if
they're asking you about the Japanese
whiskey you're drinking not yet kid but
let me tell you about it you know like I
do think Curiosity has a real play in
happiness and I've been thinking about
it a lot if you think about how parents
predominantly parent a kid they try to
scare them out of doing things it's a
very like don't do that you're going to
you know fear stop yourself sometimes I
cash yeah all of us all of us stop
saying stop don't do that that's right
all of us and listen I get it you love
them more than breathing it's the
ultimate love I do think though that
parents have to catch themselves because
these kids are getting fed fear
everywhere attention is the number one
asset